Jeden obszar, gdzie obliczenia kwantowe mogą usprawnić uczenie maszynowe,
jest związany z funkcjami jądrowymi lub
macierzami jądrowymi — sprawdźmy, czym one są.
A żeby to zrozumieć, przypomnijmy sobie
trzy rzeczy: dlaczego iloczyny skalarne pojawiają się w uczeniu maszynowym,
dlaczego problemy uczenia maszynowego dotyczą wyższych wymiarów,
i czym są funkcje jądrowe.
Przypomnij sobie, że iloczyn skalarny albo iloczyn wewnętrzny
rzeczywistych wektorów n-wymiarowych a
i b jest dany przez iloczyn modułu a,
modułu b i cosinusa kąta między nimi.
Jest to równoważne pomnożeniu
każdej składowej a przez odpowiednią składową
b i zsumowaniu. Zauważ, że jeśli wektory są
prawie ortogonalne, np. gdy a
ma zerowe składowe tam, gdzie b ma duże,
iloczyn skalarny jest mały. Jest to równoważne temu,
że kąt zbliża się do pi/2.
Podobnie, jeśli a ma ujemne składowe, a b
ma dodatnie składowe,
tzn. wektory wskazują
prawie przeciwne kierunki,
a kąt jest bliski pi,
wynik iloczynu skalarnego może być
ujemny. Na koniec, jeśli a ma duże składowe tam, gdzie b
też ma duże składowe tego samego znaku,
tzn. wektory są prawie równoległe i kąt wynosi około zera,
iloczyn skalarny będzie duży
i dodatni. Zatem jest bardzo rozsądne oczekiwać, że iloczyny skalarne
będą użyteczną miarą podobieństwa
między punktami danych. Nie każde dane n-wymiarowe
można łatwo rozdzielić w (n-1)-wymiarowym
cięciu, czyli linią,
płaszczyzną lub hiperpłaszczyzną. Gdy dane nie są dobrze rozdzielone
w n wymiarach, możemy osadzić punkty danych
w wyższych wymiarach — powiedzmy m wymiarach, gdzie m
jest większe niż n. Nazywa się to odwzorowaniem cech,
często oznaczanym jako x przechodzi w phi(x), gdzie
phi(x) jest odwzorowaniem z n-wymiarowych liczb rzeczywistych do
m-wymiarowych liczb rzeczywistych.
Najłatwiej to sobie wyobrazić, gdy
wyginamy zbiór jednowymiarowych danych do
dwóch wymiarów lub bierzemy dwuwymiarowe dane
i osadzamy je w trzech wymiarach.
Ale w rzeczywistości często osadzamy dane w przestrzeniach z tysiącami
albo nawet milionami wymiarów.
Iloczyn skalarny trójwymiarowych wektorów w porównaniu do iloczynu skalarnego
wektorów dwuwymiarowych to nieistotna różnica,
ale iloczyn skalarny wektorów milionowymiarowych
staje się całkowicie niewykonalny
dla dużych zbiorów danych.
Dlatego wymyślono sprytną sztuczkę:
co jeśli użyć projekcji
do wyższych wymiarów o bardzo szczególnej formie,
takiej że iloczyny skalarne wektorów
w wyższych wymiarach są prostą funkcją
wektorów w niższych wymiarach? Innymi słowy, szukamy odwzorowania
naszych danych x do wymiaru wyższego phi(x),
takiego że iloczyn wewnętrzny
w przestrzeni cech jest dany prostą
funkcją w danych niższego wymiaru.
Ta funkcja k jest nazywana funkcją jądrową.
Ideałem byłoby, gdyby ta funkcja jądrowa
była funkcją samego iloczynu wewnętrznego
w niższym wymiarze — dałoby nam to
to, co najlepsze z obu światów: bardzo wysokowymiarową przestrzeń cech,
ale z tanim i łatwym do obliczenia iloczynem wewnętrznym.
Na pierwszy rzut oka może nie być
oczywiste, że to w ogóle możliwe. Przyjrzyjmy się
jednemu prostemu przykładowi w bardzo niskich wymiarach.
Rozważ to konkretne odwzorowanie cech: mapuje ono
trójwymiarowy wektor na
przestrzeń dziewięciowymiarową. Okazuje się,
że iloczyn wewnętrzny dziewięciowymiarowej przestrzeni cech
jest po prostu dany iloczynem wewnętrznym w oryginalnej
przestrzeni 3D do kwadratu. Czyli iloczyn wewnętrzny
w przestrzeni po odwzorowaniu za pomocą funkcji phi
wymagałby obliczenia każdej z
dziewięciu współrzędnych pierwszego
wektora i dziewięciu dla
drugiego, a następnie samego iloczynu wewnętrznego, czyli
kolejnych dziewięciu mnożeń i sumy —
to łącznie dwadzieścia osiem operacji.
Funkcja jądrowa wymaga trzech mnożeń
i dwóch sumowań, co odpowiada zaledwie czterem operacjom.
To było dla odwzorowania trójwymiarowego punktu danych do
dziewięciowymiarowej przestrzeni cech.
Łatwo zauważyć, że może to być bardzo korzystne
dla bardzo dużych przestrzeni.
Funkcja jądrowa jest zazwyczaj ciągłą funkcją,
którą można zastosować do dowolnego wektora w zbiorze danych.
Ale funkcji jądrowych używamy, pobierając
pary punktów danych z naszego zbioru
jako argumenty. Zastosowanie funkcji jądrowej do
każdej pary punktów danych ze zbioru
daje symetryczną macierz zwaną macierzą
jądrową. Rodzaj funkcji jądrowej, której użyjesz, zależy od
twojego problemu. Podsumowując:
opisywanie podobieństwa wektorów w naszych zbiorach danych
często wymaga iloczynów wewnętrznych. Iloczyny wewnętrzne
w bardzo wysokowymiarowych przestrzeniach cech są kosztowne,
więc używamy odwzorowań cech odpowiadających
pewnym specjalnym funkcjom jądrowym,
które sprawiają, że obliczenia są wydajniejsze.
Ale to ograniczenie do specjalnych funkcji jądrowych
ogranicza też to, jakie odwzorowania w przestrzeń cech mogą być
wykonane wydajnie. To
może uniemożliwić nam dobre rozdzielenie danych.
Gdyby tylko istniał inny sposób...
Tutaj właśnie wkraczają obliczenia kwantowe.
Bardzo wysokowymiarowe odwzorowanie cech odpowiadające
funkcjom jądrowym może być wykonane
na komputerze kwantowym w kwantowym estymatorze jądrowym.
Macierz jądrowa k jest obliczana,
a następnie klasyczny algorytm uczenia maszynowego może zostać użyty
do realizacji zadania. Jeden punkt danych x1
jest wczytywany i odwzorowywany, a następnie
wczytywany jest kolejny x2
i odwzorowywany. Ponieważ iloczyn wewnętrzny dwóch stanów kwantowych
jest związany z prawdopodobieństwem pomiaru,
możemy oszacować iloczyn wewnętrzny dwóch odwzorowanych
punktów danych, wykonując wystarczająco wiele pomiarów
wynikowego circuit. W ten sposób nasz circuit
może powiedzieć nam o iloczynie wewnętrznym
w dowolnej wysokowymiarowej przestrzeni, którą circuit może modelować,
bez konieczności klasycznego obliczania iloczynu wewnętrznego czy
funkcji jądrowej. Istnieje wiele sposobów
dostosowywania i ulepszania tych metod,
i rzeczywiście wciąż proponowane są nowe metody,
które są testowane. Mamy nadzieję, że to
omówienie pomogło zarysować
zastosowanie obliczeń kwantowych
w metodach uczenia maszynowego,
zwłaszcza tych dotyczących jąder.